hey youtubers is Charlie welcome to part
2 of my legend of korra book 2 finale
this will be 4 episodes 13 and 14
so they aired it early on Nick comm and
we got a bunch of our big questions
answered Jinora helped Korra find raava
inside of the dark avatar a new avatar
cycle was started and Korra left the
spirit portals open allowing spirits to
roam free going forward the episodes
also paid big reference to a major plot
point from Avatar The Last Airbender
I've also got details on the DVD
giveaway I'll be doing for book 2 as
soon as they start releasing those as
well as the book 3 videos that I'm going
to be doing going forward so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
let's do our top 5 favorite moments from
the two-part finale then I'll explain
some of the more technical aspects of
what happened especially with the energy
bending and then I'll do my review
number 1 vaatu fused with unlock as
predicted forming the dark avatar they
severed course connection with raava and
then destroyed her basically erasing her
avatar hard drive and cutting her off
from her past lives I loved unlock
during this whole sequence he basically
became this comic book villain if he
ever saw the 1990s Batman the Animated
Series he actually had Joker face but
anytime Avatar does something that it's
never done before it's a huge deal and
we've never seen dark avatar before on
the series obviously after the results
of the finale we're not going to see
another dark avatar for another 10,000
years at least but anytime they try
something new I give them a giant
high-five just to explain what happened
when they fuse so Luna Locke became more
of a conduit for vaatu so normally you
think that vaatu would just be able to
sever raava's connection on his own he
wouldn't need to bond with the human to
do that but what happens this is when a
spirit bonds with a human like raava and
vaatu did they gain access to the
spiritual energy you know when Korra was
energy bending at the end of the episode
so it wasn't just about unlock becoming
more powerful but to gain access to new
energy as well that's how they were able
to form that super dark spirit avatar at
the end number 2 Korra learn to energy
Bend with the help of Tenzin and the
Tree of Life
this paid huge reference to the avatar
last airbender episode from book 2
episode 19 the Guru where a learned
about his chakras and learns to connect
with himself spiritually in the way that
Korra does so she can energy Bend so
when you see her walking around in space
trying to connect with herself that's
that cosmic level of spirituality
that guru Pathik was helping aang with
if you recall energy bending is called
the loss form of bending that's just
because people have forgotten how to
connect with themselves on that cosmic
level but the interesting thing is is
that Korra still needs generous help to
find the good inside a vaatu to find
raava inside of vaatu that basically
just implies that Jinora is just the
most powerful spiritual person on Quora
right now or at least the most in tune
with her spirituality number three Korra
defeats vaatu and unlock or the dark
avatar however you want to think of them
healing unlock in the process and
basically suppressing vaatu for another
ten thousand years so we will not see a
dark avatar again because unlock was
killed while they were in the Avatar
state he's basically dead he's not
coming back to the cycle of resurrection
will not happen but over the next 10,000
years vaatu will slowly grow out of
raava so whoever's avatar in 10,000
years will basically have to go through
this all again especially if vaatu tries
to form another dark avatar so number
four braava is pulled out of korra and
basically suppressed or destroyed
temporarily erasing Cora's avatar
harddrive so all those past lives those
past avatars
they weren't destroyed in the process
they're just cut off from Cornell so
there are people talking to spirits all
the time in the world of avatar the last
airbender as well as legend of korra so
they're still out there they're just
living in the giant spiritual data cloud
now with guru Pathik
so Korra just does not have direct and
constant access to them like she did
when she was avatar all that means is
that she is basically starting a new
cycle of avatar just like Wan did when
he first bonded with raava
so essentially she's the first avatar of
a new line of avatars and number five
Korra left the spirit portals open
allowing spirits to pass into the
physical realm and roam free with humans
this is gonna figure into books three
and four but now spirits will be roaming
everywhere we will definitely be seeing
a lot of old spirits come back in book
three and book four so if you have any
favorite spirits like the face of Ko
they'll probably come back in book three
and four book three by the way is also
an earth Kingdom book they're gonna be
dealing with a lot of earth Kingdom
stories just like avatar last airbender
so it's all about cycles but what did I
think of the finale overall beginnings
is still my favorite episode of legend
of korra of all time but i really like
the way that the finale paid off a lot
of classic stories like the guru as well
as answering a lot of our big questions
and
an interesting place to go in books
three and four especially with all the
spirits flying around now the only thing
I thought they could have done better
was explain a little bit more about the
technical aspects of what Korra was
doing with her powers in this final
battle
so just because kor became the avatar
she was born as the avatar as a baby did
not mean she automatically knew how to
use all of her powers instantly and
basically in this episode she learns to
energy been within like two minutes and
automatically knows how to use all of
those powers so that's my only small
complaint it's not a big complaint but
this is only because avatar Legend of
Korra has half the number of episodes
that avatar last airbender had to tell
the same story let me know in the
comments what are your favorite moments
from the finale as well as your general
thoughts on book 2 as a whole I'll be
doing another separate video just to
review book 2 as a whole next week be
sure to subscribe to get it
they're gonna be airing the finale again
on TV so here's the details on my korra
book 2 DVD giveaway as well as my book 3
videos so they haven't announced a
release date for the book to DVD yet but
as soon as they do i'll be giving away a
couple free copies and i'll be doing a
weekly Korra video going forward every
week until we get to book 3 so if you've
ever seen any of my Game of Thrones
videos you know that I do a lot of Game
of Thrones even though there's no Game
of Thrones on TV right now so I'll be
doing the same thing with Korra
I'll also be looking for a new anime or
animation show to do based on your guys
recommendations be sure to let me know
in the comments what do you think I
should start doing videos for it can be
anything like one piece or Naruto but I
just ask that it be relatively new and
coming soon right now click here to get
my part 1 video for The Legend of Korra
finale and click here to learn all about
my Doctor Who 50th anniversary DVD
giveaway thank you so much for watching
high fives I'll see you guys tonight